look who's joined our program one of our
favorites and it's just because he's
with jessica's guests really it doesn't
matter what time of year obviously it
helps the the nfl season's right around
the corner
and uh and he's one of our favorites
he's all pro tight end 50th on the top
100 best players in the nfl list on nfl
networks voted by his peers george
kettle back in the richardson show how
are you george
good morning rich how are you doing
today i am doing better for seeing you
i'm doing
well i wish i was seeing you well i'm
seeing you right now the photograph that
we're we're using on the screen is the
the photograph that we get from the
49ers
um you you've got i mean this is uh i
mean how long is your hair right now
george i mean this thing
it's fine
we did those photos during uh otas this
year and i actually i cut off about i
don't know like six to eight inches okay
it's about half that length right now
all right i had to get all my photos in
with the long hair just for fun that is
that so this is a conscious choice like
okay that was a conscious choice okay so
this is the photograph that people are
going to use for the entire 2021 season
we're using it for the very first time
um
breaking news rich eisen this is flow
man this is flow i like the flow man i
like it a lot going on there i like it i
like it very much have you ever seen the
film almost famous you ever seen that
movie
almost famous i don't think i have okay
well it's a there's a a fake rock band
called stillwater in it and we've
photoshopped you into that photograph um
i guess and it looks real this looks
this looks real um
if this inspires you to see the film
fantastic if it doesn't this is
something that we're going to tweet out
anyway okay i just looked it up yeah i
would fit in there we'll dm them right
now we'll dm them right now fantastic by
the way nice flex to show that george
follows us and we follow them tj well
done i appreciate that that was a nice
place all right so we're uh so um you're
gonna tell us who the starting
quarterback for week one is going to be
right that's uh that's what we're going
to get from you in three two and one
floor is yours what do you got george
sorry you broke up there
not george kennel's first rodeo people
all right how how what what is it like
to be i guess um
um
there's someone saying in the middle
because that that that is rife with uh
verbiage that makes it seem like there's
there's something wrong but what is it
like to experience this how does that
sound uh a guy that you played with went
to super bowl with and a kid who's so
highly drafted that a ton of pics are
used to go get him what's that like
george for you
um
i'm just kind of experiencing the day to
day you know i get a bunch of reps with
both quarterbacks you know um
like you said you know jimmy's been the
cat been the captain in the leader of
this team he still is uh he's playing at
a super high level with us in practice
and
you know we had a 17 play drive to open
up monday night well sunday night
football and yes um
you know trey's learning he's getting
better every single day um he's got a
cannon for an arm he can make a bunch of
throws it's fun to see that stuff and
obviously he still has a ton to learn so
now we're staying a day by day and we're
all just out there practicing trying to
get better as a team and
um you know i think uh both guys are
made a lot of strides i think uh tonight
and i think uh kyle said earlier in the
season that you know jimmy had his best
otas and i think jimmy's still firing
along right now so i see jimmy i see
jimmy's confidence and i decided that i
think he had to play a little bit this
sunday versus the raiders so we'll have
a full team out there finally did you
see what uh shanahan said when somebody
said when are you going to tell us who
the starting quarterback is did you see
that when i want to
i love it
i said that's the guy who once upon a
time said we don't know if we're going
to be alive sunday so what sort of
answer you expecting from this guy you
know i think that was my first thought
when i saw that quote i was like he's
just a quote machine right now he is i
mean he just spits truth um there's
there's no doubt about it but you know
and and and so many people think that
this is an untenable situation but the
world keeps spinning and you know at
some point you're gonna get a guy and
then you're gonna go battle and you're
gonna go you're gonna go hit it
what does this offense look like in your
estimation in 2021 regardless of who's
at the quarterback what is the plan here
and the goal
george for you in 2021 here
my goal would be to run the heck out of
the ball because we're pretty good at
that we i think we have a really good
offensive line i think we have really
talented running backs decent tight ends
on the edges
um and then we got wide shears that can
block and so if you can establish a run
game i think the rest just takes care of
itself and i think we got explosive guys
that you get the ball to from you know
diva to iuke to trent sherfield to you
know you get rahim out there um you know
we got plenty of guys that can make
plays when you get the ball in their
hands and as long as we can establish a
good run game which i think we'll be
able to do with mcglinchey and trent
williams as our tackles i think they're
both decent the run game yes but um
i'm just i'm just excited to get the
ball rolling with it and like i said i'm
pumped to you know get all the starters
out there on sunday so we all just get
an actual feel for it and a little game
day atmosphere and i'm just looking
forward to seeing uh that run game
really that's what i'm focused on
uh because if we can move that ball uh
we're gonna get a lot of those little
play actions i can you know sneak out
sneak down the middle maybe once or
twice and have some fun well give me a
good trent williams story seeing him up
close give me a good one you got one
george about where you're like okay i
get it i knew it but now i really see it
you got a good one on that front with
him oh my goodness i mean from sharing
the huddle to him but
hey i mean being in the huddle with him
but really when you see the giant
silverback tattoo on his back that kind
of sets the tone pretty quick it's a
tone setter okay that's a toad said
that's the tone pretty quick you know
what yeah
you've got my back i understand that
yeah yeah thanks for playing enough
tackle with me literally man i mean and
so
so you will look to your right and
that's trent williams and that must make
you feel like we're going to run and
we're going to hit somebody and you what
is it like for you to pancake someone
can you walk me through that i know that
if we we've even mooch has even spot
shotted you on a sunday morning show
where you're like laughing after you're
smiling like it seems like you enjoy
that more than anything else can you
walk me through that process for you
george kittle do me that favor
uh well something i learned at iowa
you're never going to play in the big 10
unless you can run block and so you kind
of have to be passionate about the run
game especially if you i was really
really bad at it in college and so
either to love it or i was just going to
hate it for five years and so i decided
to love it
and i'm glad that i did because it kind
of set the tone for everything and you
know kind of my whole career um just the
physicality and effort and so
um
my favorite quote that i learned while i
was in iowa is moving a man from point a
to point b against as well is the
greatest feeling you ever feel and i 100
agree with that um because
i mean there's nothing that the guy can
do if you can actually just move him
about five yards outside the numbers and
on top of that if you can get him off of
his feet and slap back him and land on
top of him and feel them exhale and a
little bit of that you know
that sold him in his body type of
experiences it's very thrilling um it's
very addicting and that's why it is the
best feeling you ever feel
and how how big is lance like
i i've not seen him in person i've only
seen him on tv he just looks huge george
i mean what
walk me through that one too
trey
segway from pancake into trey lance you
want me to pancake tray land no
no no i would never want you to do a dog
he's a large human being um
it messes me up that he's only 21 years
old because i'm like dude i'm 27 and
you're the og you're the og yeah you're
gonna i was like you're just three years
you're gonna be an actual like an adult
and uh it'll be crazy to see what you
look like then well i'm trying to get
you to talk about your quarterback
number five you know george you know i
mean and i i i realized i kind of put
you in a position before i i'm about
talking about him and jimmy g i didn't
want you to feel like i put your good
positions both my teammates man i'll
hype them both up all day every day okay
i like i want them both to succeed at a
high level all right fantastic how did
the tight end um
tight end university go your first one
we haven't spoken since then
yes it was awesome
i loved every second of it it was uh
incredible i got super lucky uh with
some fantastic sponsors that we we got
the entire event paid for except for the
guys flights in so
nice event
stay at a nice hotel had meetings gotta
watch film gotta listen to some really
um talented players talk from kelsey to
olsen darren waller mercedes-lewis got
to get on the field do some drills just
kind of it was more just like listening
to guys talk about the way they think
about running routes or run game or
attacking zones attacking leverages
and it was just nice to hear you know
different takes on it because when
you're you know you're in a tight end
room with your coach like you can learn
like you can learn a lot obviously like
i've learned so much from my titan coach
john embry he's fantastic and he's one
of the main reasons i am where i am
today but let's see now like how travis
kelsey sees um like a leverage on a guy
and how he attacks it differently it's
just um or even like he could say hey i
tag it like this and if it's similar
it's like all right well i'm glad i'm
learning the right thing
and then
you you get to watch all these guys on
tape um you know how they do certain
things and then listen to them say why
they did those things it kind of
connects all the dots for you so you're
not just sitting there guessing and
asking why he did that and so it was
very it was very fun for me i love that
that's amazing that greg olson talked to
was it was incredible
that's great man so like literally so
you're just sitting around and talking
about
everything to do with blocking and and
this is what i do when i have leverage
that's what i do in this coverage that's
what i do with that and and it confirmed
some things for you and opened some
doors like literally even for you george
at this 100 rich man one thing i've
learned is
i don't know anything about anything i'm
just learning every single day and no i
i've had some good years but i'm in year
five and i still know i can learn a
whole bunch and um especially from guys
i've been doing a long time like greg
olsen had plenty of saying i told you
like mercedes lewis is going into i
think year 17 and he was up there on the
mic for about 45 minutes and just listen
to him talk about his whole experience
in the nfl in his life and how he got to
where he is today because i think
playing 17 years in the nfl is one of
the coolest accomplishments you can
possibly do because i think everyone's
goals you know i think it's like the
average years like our average career is
like three to five years so going to 17
is pretty impressive so just listening
all those guys talk about their careers
was pretty special well and you know i i
like i said if you can do it again i'll
i'll help out in any way i can certainly
with the curriculum i'll add a new thing
for you um that kelsey has proven don't
shave without expecting some blowback
from your fan base did you see that yeah
george did you see that that he had us
yeah that was his i made i changed it to
his caller id pretty quick
which one the the clean shaver and the
one where he scrawled on his own feet
defaced his own selfie clean shave i
zoomed it in as tight as you could zoom
it in and that's his car right here
so when travis kelsey calls george
kittle's cell phone that that that
shaved mug show we just zoomed in
ourselves wow that is we just did it
ourselves right here so that's what
shows up on your phone wow yeah okay
beautiful
it's shiny that's for sure
it's wonderful it's glistening uh george
thanks for the time uh i greatly
appreciate it let's do this more often
certainly in the season when you begin
to ball out and uh i always appreciate
it best your family
hey thank you rich thanks for having me
on it's always a pleasure i love when
you asked me quarterback questions thank
you no i know i certainly when you have
to choose between one or the other
that's what i'll expect next time you
choose yeah
no i'll just i'll announce the starters
all right
you do it on your own time just like
your coach whenever you want but i
appreciate it
yes sir take care right back that's
george kill everybody
i love george
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here